[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks here we are we might be drunk
oh we're white powering out of the gate
here
good to see ya my brain is mush sam's
hung over and rosebud's sober yeah we're
still drinking the worst of all three
i don't know look at us no we're not
we're not doing well
this is rough we uh yeah i went hard
last night it was one of those like an
also construction in my building so it
was like i went hard and i just knew
this morning would suck yeah you did but
what are you gonna do that's brutal yeah
you're off you're hungover you're off a
bender my parents are in town and i was
on the fully loaded tour all weekend my
brain is mush yeah yeah
how long are they here
uh till thursday okay
so bad not so bad our parents randomly
had dinner together yes i forgot me
randomly mark mark's dad and my dad have
a mutual friend uh-huh and they all just
had dinner so my mom said we're having
dinner with uh the normans tonight i was
like what i know i couldn't wrap my head
around the world's colliding it was too
much mark since i was at the cellar late
last night and marcher sends me a
picture of our families together and i'm
like this is can i post that on here is
that is that weird i don't let me let me
send it to matt you could throw it up on
the on the uh that's the problem so
they're meeting uh both your spouses
it's really great i do feel like we just
got serious
yeah yeah like we were friends for years
we just took it up a level that's a good
point
i don't feel comfortable i just
preferred [ __ ]
[Laughter]
yeah so my parents are in town meeting
my fiance's parents for the first time
and i can't relax i'm freaking out i'm
nervous that's a terrifying thing to
have happen yeah i got married during
covet so i got to avoid all of it yeah
like
none of my family they haven't met
andy's uh parents well they met um
andy's dad and stepmom but they did they
haven't met his mom
anita
and that's the she's the you know the
matriarch really and the patriarch
wow are you are you in good with her
yeah yeah that's good she's
we're a lot alike she he married his mom
yes like look at that there's my sleepy
dad yeah norman's parents in the middle
mine on on you know
that's cute yeah it's pretty funny i
knew your mom sam because of uh kovid
you would run jokes by yeah
dark times
and my mom doesn't know i do stand up oh
that's good
yeah she's got a nice farrah fawcett
thing cooking yeah
good bangs it's like a threes company
good for her this is like the new uh
grace and frankie here
yeah
oh yeah this is funny you definitely
look like both your parents well that's
my that's not my biological debt no i'm
saying i'm saying uh that that mark does
uh-huh yeah you look like your mom yeah
i can see yeah
cute cute family
very cute
the the foursome though is when they
went too far i thought it was pretty fun
i thought it was pretty weird they all
[ __ ] but yeah whatever well how are
you gonna get to know each other yeah
exactly
my mom's gonna listen to this and she's
gonna be like why did you make that joke
blame it on me
i'm a bad influence i feel like i get
that a lot from my parents like whenever
they hear a joke they go like why did
you why that
that's why yeah because of that right
yeah you realize like the line
most comedians line of how far they go
is their parents right right right
sexually and comedy wise you know what i
mean absolutely sexually it's actually
for sure how did you guys do it
i mean but no but don't you realize that
with comedy where you're like my the the
joke i go my mom would go sam i'm like
that's okay that's where i'll go right
yeah she'd get mad yeah and i think we
don't feel that much so like you got to
say something crazy i was on this tour
bus saying horrible [ __ ] and then i got
out in front of like the grips and the
other people and i said a uvaldi joke
and they were all like
right what the [ __ ] was that i was like
oh i was joking like that's a joke i'm
like to me
i just think the worst thing i can to
get a reaction
i like that you said that that we don't
feel that much that's that made me feel
better that's right yeah well it's not
that we were sociopath we just the words
are numb
you know right and when you started open
mics you're just around people saying
the most horrible [ __ ] ever and then
you're like oh okay you're numb we're
desensitized i mean you know it's that's
it's not you know we're not bad people i
don't think i don't know no no of course
not yeah it's debatable it's debatable
but i do think that like when when like
covet hit and [ __ ] and i would be
reading the news and all of a sudden
like it started to like affect me i was
like oh no this is bad yeah it was like
the scabs of years of talking to other
comics we were just sort of like
wearing down and i was like oh i'm not
as funny anymore like
i can tell because i'm reading the news
and nothing's coming to mind except this
is tragic you know like yes and that was
like a bad sign yeah when you when you
have uh empathy right i felt it coming
back i was like oh no this is gonna be
so bad for me you have to distance
yourself right that's like that's like
the comedic trait where you're like it
doesn't mean that we don't feel but it
means like we have to we have to kind of
immediately distance ourselves or else
there's no joke yeah yeah yeah you're
dissociated a little bit yeah and it
sucks that we can't we grieve our way
you know you go to a funeral people are
crying and they're hugging the casket
going no
and i'm going hey
uh
you know he's got a boner in there and
they're like what's wrong with him this
is how i agree
you know why i grieve the way i grieve
comics funerals are the best oh the best
those are [ __ ] great you trash a dead
person yeah it's fun
that's literally the jewish faith we
dump the rocks on the you know really on
the casket you just start throwing the
rocks on the cats
wait what yeah you don't see that ever
no i didn't know about the rocks you
pushed the rocks on yeah i thought that
was a muslim thing
that's when women try to vote
or drive
how do you like uh writing for snl right
now um well i'm not right now thank you
so much thank you look at that it just
went on break about to relapse uh yeah
you sure that's the right one
okay
um
i do like it oh my god that's so good
yeah for rosebud we're we're going well
what is that a rose yeah it tastes like
jesus are you trying to [ __ ] us it
tastes like my mom's soap
i feel like it's it's been great like it
was kind of like it felt like going to
uh like getting paid to go to harvard or
something for a little while you know
yeah comedy school that's my favorite
it's not my type of it's well made it's
just not my type of cocktail i like to
like potpourri for you it's a little too
potpourri i love a rose flavor or
anything yeah no it's interesting i feel
like i'm the the girl in american beauty
right now you know
your tits are bigger
[Laughter]
that was funny
never mind well that's one of those
movies where you're like i was like this
is amazing and then five years later i
was like this movie kind of sucks yeah
absolutely it's pretentious yeah yeah
very precious the bag floating get out
of here yeah the the monologue at the
end yeah
spacey is great and annette benning's
hot and great oh yeah yeah yeah it's
plowed by peter gallagher
good time you can tell how much older
i'm getting but every time i watch that
movie i relate more and more to her
being like don't get anything on the
couch and more on her side yeah as i get
older i'm like no i completely get it oh
yeah i saw peter gallagher in a bodega
once when i was like we were like
must've been like eighth or ninth grade
and we're all like hammered did you guys
have an eyebrow off
i don't know who to want that's a tough
one right
i was me and my friends were shit-faced
holding like 40s we're holding like oh
and i was like you're [ __ ] peter
gallagher and he was just like ugh and
his wife goes no that's nice
oh really that was like a drunk film
nerd yeah yeah yeah that's a pretty big
deal
you knew that was as a kid yeah that's
pretty good i'd seen while you were
sleeping i'd seen a bunch of his [ __ ] oh
yeah guys and dolls
what happened to his eyebrows he shaved
him he lost a bit
[Laughter]
oh wow he is a completely different man
without those things he looks like
thomas hayden church without those so
hot is he a hot guy he is a hot guy yeah
he's a good looking dude i can't tell
he's definitely a romantic lead oh yeah
that's true
okay but so is seth rogen you know what
he's like uh he's like a hotter um
what's his name's uh saturday night
fever why am i blinking yeah he's a
hotter he's hotter than travolta yeah
travolta because travolta um
ended up yeah first of all gay second
has that scientology smile yes yes you
know he's got a glow of like i've been
i've been uh transformed yeah like
there's just like nothing behind his
[ __ ] eyes right i'm in a cult i'm not
turned down by that though yeah yeah
of course we were talking about snl
sorry i cut you off with american beauty
yeah um it's been it's been cool it's
been like
i mean physically it's just [ __ ] so
hard on you yeah uh you're doing the
road yeah and i'm doing the road and
like i uh but it it's a cool thing to be
this
like far into comedy and go oh here's
something that i never really learned
how to do
and like to try to teach yourself that
from zero yes because writing live
sketch versus writing sketch for tv is
just such a completely different animal
right and
um
nothing can be subtle like subtlety
never plays
it has to be like
really [ __ ] obvious or else the
audience in the room doesn't get it you
know
not to mention you are doing these for
like tourists yes right and young people
and young people yeah and i've seen your
act a bunch you're pretty dry yeah you
know we're both pretty dry yeah so like
i wonder how that is to write
big broad kind of sketches
well it's good because i'm like i never
really i'm not that silly yes you know
and so to be in that environment and to
kind of like learn how to be funny in
that way
that's been really cool for me are you
silly with andy yes yeah so it's like
you have that but then you have to make
it broad right yeah yeah yeah so it's a
different it's just a different skill
set and i remember
going in and watching like the first
table read and hearing one of my
sketches and going oh that was real bad
and and the scariest part of that was i
have no idea why
oh like
it's one thing to bomb and know exactly
what happened it's another thing to bomb
and be like
i don't know how i'm going to avoid that
yeah and you know you're the newer
person yes what do people say when when
it bombs like that does do they say
anything they don't say anything it's
like you i wish you could just be like
skip it you know like i wish you could
be up in the bleachers just like just
skip it it's fine there's [ __ ] seven
more pages just get just move on you
know
but they have to read the whole thing
so and sometimes you'll see lauren like
looking how many pages are left oh wow
you're like that's the youtube you press
the button yeah yeah thank god 20
seconds yeah you're like oh [ __ ] yeah
but it's uh
but like finally by the end of the
season i would be writing stuff and i
would know exactly what wasn't gonna
play and why it wasn't gonna play and
and then to see it
like play out exactly how i thought it
would i'd be like oh okay i finally know
what i'm doing wrong i can't say i've
gotten great at it like i still feel
like i have no business being there but
i
i'm like i'm learning it yeah you know
and they let you learn they don't go ah
you you tried and failed well we'll see
i mean i still haven't i'm gonna find
out we know a couple people got in and
out pretty quick well i mean it's a high
pressure job i thought bill hader in an
interview just be like yeah i was
miserable
yeah yeah yeah i mean there's like i
think there's
times when you're miserable but it's
like
this is just from what i've observed i
it it's still there's something so kind
of like addicting about it yeah i mean
it's the same as stand-up you know it's
so intense you're like putting
everything into it you let your personal
life fall to pieces and you just [ __ ]
throw your whole self into it so it's
yeah it's misery but comedy is misery oh
literally the last two nights i had no
sets i was like
i think i had two last night and then
sunday at nine i just text liz the
seller i'm like uh if anyone cancels
she's like chris red's stuck in canada
you want to do four i'm like yep
then he's still stuck in canada monday
she's like you want to do another three
so i'm just like yep i'm just at the
seller i'm like yeah let's just neglect
my entire life
downing [ __ ] booze at the at the fat
black bar greg stone started a show
called night cream yeah
where he just sings auto tune yeah it's
incredible he's murdering me
there's an audience there's an audience
dude he started that during the pandemic
it's incredible yeah dude he can kind of
sing
it's weird so he it's stand up and at
the end of the show greg just starts
doing auto-tune and being [ __ ] crazy
and he's doing bits kind of through it
it's murdering yeah come on so funny and
then everyone's just hanging out having
fun and just every i'm like it's like a
party hopefully i do it every monday at
the fat black lives
matter it's worth going to it's crazy
yeah it's really funny he did didn't he
like do a music video as night cream
his band is like it's called night cream
and it's him and another comic and they
they basically like wrote an album in
one day during the pandemic and it's all
improvised and
it's hilarious i mean i'm just like it's
the craziest thing night cream maybe i
don't know is it
is it jokes i don't get where the laughs
come weird it's i don't know it's all
it's improvised it's so silly it's he
takes something someone says and turns
into a song but it's [ __ ] weird and
silly it's like singing crowd work yeah
almost yeah yeah pretty much
i don't know if there's going to be a
good clip or not because i haven't seen
this it looks like so yeah i don't think
this is the uh i don't think this is the
music video okay oh there's a music
video yeah we don't want to play a
standout this is a comedy show
just joking greg this is a music video
night cream that's a great name
uh by the way this drink gets better
every single yeah actually it's growing
on me yeah
i was gonna have an alternative for you
but if you need another one
no the raspberry and the raspberry
needed a second
we gotta get greg on here yeah greg's
gonna come on he's so funny maybe he
could do this on the pod yes
[Music]
yeah chopping wood is what he calls sex
so the song is chopping wood
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right it's funny it's pretty funny
i'm sorry i don't mean to just play a
whole thing here but i thought it was it
was fun check it out he's doing it at
the comedy cellar hopefully every monday
it's like a whole show
devito went on simeon goodson who's
hilarious also yeah it was a good show
all right wow how did they pitch that
one
liz somehow saw it
i don't know if she started another club
and she was like you got to do this i
bet you he showed her the music video i
bet that's what it was but she was
pumped for it yeah it's very funny this
[ __ ] might be crazy
so yeah what were like highlights were
there any guests you were like or host
this season we were like oh this is
pretty awesome um it's so
like
it's so it's such a lame answer but i
can barely remember the hosts like
because you're so it's a world sleep
deprived and [ __ ] but i gotta say like
lizzo was [ __ ] great she she really
like
she knew she she hosted and she was a
musical guest and she did update during
the dress rehearsal so i've never seen
anybody do that much work like
she when i went into her dressing room
to give her notes she was every time i
saw her off stage she was lying down she
was just like
literally preserving all her energy yes
and and then i saw her
i was literally like this [ __ ] i get it
like for her to lie down the whole time
i was like that's perfect that's what we
should be doing yes exactly because you
lose so much energy talking to the the
manager of the club the waiter the fans
the photos after you just burnt out yeah
and i don't i don't know anybody who's
been a host and a musical guest that's
also wanted to do update that's like
your time off true true you know i heard
about this i think i've told this before
but it was a rock star i'm not going to
say his name but he puts his hood up and
that means don't talk to me and then
he'll take the hood down and anybody can
say hello how are you take a photo so
that's like his way of nicely saying
leave me the [ __ ] alone i heard the case
[Laughter]
sorry i stepped on that that was funny
well air pods i think somebody can still
go
yeah and you gotta do this [ __ ] you know
but with the hood up everybody just knew
that was his rule oh that's a that's a
[ __ ] peeve the airpods in it is a
peeve of mine yeah i get why people do
it but it bugs me a little bit when they
don't take them out yeah when they're
just talking you with the airpods yeah
that is weird because you get a lot of
what yes right i saw a guy in front of
me at the bank doing that i'm like just
take him out for the conversation right
right exactly
but how many people are you approaching
with airpods in very i'm not doing it i
mean sometimes i have men someone's you
see someone in the street you take them
out for the conversation right yeah but
then maybe it's a conversation you want
to have a really long one so you take
one out one right exactly that's what i
do huh huh yeah but talk about snl i
read the the bernie brillstein book and
jim john baloo she said he did four
years and he said it's like high school
yeah you do four years and you graduate
yeah well keenan's been there for like
20 years right yeah well a lot of the
cast has been there for
van wylder
yeah
i think that there's like i think before
80 and kyle and kate
uh and and
[ __ ] 80 kyle's still there kate
mckinnon no she's no she just left she
left okay um but like
i think the cast had been there the
longest of annie cast oh wow yeah that
they were just like sticking around for
a while i wonder if it's just terrifying
because you have it's not like the old
days where you just were guaranteed they
don't make comedy movies anymore really
right like back in the day you were just
in a movie yeah i graduated people but
you look at a lot of those snl guys from
back you know like what 12 years ago or
so and they all have their own shows
like you look at like you know uh
jason sedakis and bill hader and uh i
mean a lot of them just had their own
but it did take long like the way that
the entertainment industry has changed
i'm like it takes so much longer to
build
sort of longevity you know because you
have
there's
you can have your own show but that
doesn't mean everybody's gonna watch it
it's like there's so many platforms and
there's so many different ways to watch
things that you could have a massively
successful show on one platform and
people just still don't [ __ ] know
about it yeah there's so many shows that
we don't know about i know i put on i i
was with a girl the other night i put on
uh 30 rock and she's like what is this
what
i mean she was 14. but uh no no but she
was like what is this and i was like
are you kidding me she goes if she was
tina fey and i was like yeah it's like
one of the best shows ever what are you
talking about damn and then uh did she
not know who tina fey was she did but
she was like yeah she's not funny and i
was like are you kidding me are you
[ __ ] serious
and she was like alec baldwin i was like
this is like one of the best comic
actors ever what are you talking about
did something happen
you're like he's a little rusty
that was the name of the movie
um but uh
yeah yeah so you're right they don't
make comedy movies like they used to no
it's like it is no they don't they
definitely i missed the 90s in that way
because like how many we can't say they
were all [ __ ] great you know they
were it's like they had rodney king
right that was 92.
i mean if you look at like how many of
those uh actually did not do great in
the box office oh the movies yeah i'm
talking about the ones that came out
no no no
no yeah you're right yeah i thought you
were talking about a hit
and i was like yeah that did
definitely got great ratings
but yeah we had well yeah tommy boy but
then you had knight at the roxbury i
thought roxbury was kind of fun
it's got a moment yeah it's got moments
there's a moment i don't know i mean if
you look at i don't know i don't
remember a single moment from it though
same
but before it was just like the natural
progression was like you had molly
shannon do what's her face uh catherine
gallagher right and then she did
superstar yeah yeah the knight of the
roxbury with will ferrell and uh what's
his face katan and then it became a
movie it was just such a normal
trajectory and now that's over yeah i
mean will ferrell kind of
was the king of the 90s like every movie
that he was involved in besides night at
the roxbury yeah i mean it was just i
was like re-watching anchorman which has
kind of been ruined at this point just
from the amount of like
times it's been quoted to me
but
yeah but like
that movie was so [ __ ] good yeah oh
amazing it was so funny anchorman um the
other guys have you guys seen that oh
yeah that's one of his later movies it's
a great old school that's like
actually i'm surprised by how many
people haven't seen the other guys true
it's great it's so funny yeah yeah oh
step brothers
yeah step brothers but a lot of those
were like the early odds i feel like the
90s was like it was like sandler
talladega nights
jim carrey chris tucker that's like
eddie murphy still yeah you know like
how you talk to your dad about baseball
if you have a bad relationship
mine is all me and my dad talk about our
will feral movies and that's right yeah
that's like how we keep our relationship
on safe territory i remember i remember
my biological father his wife said just
come over there'll be a baseball game on
like all right fine and then i get
there's no game on him like i was told
there'd be a buffer this is [ __ ] rude
we saw i remember we saw that you just
have to make strong eye contact all day
i remember he'd remember he took me to
see walk hard he was i don't see
something mindless and the whole as
mindless it is there's still a subplot
of like he's like i'm sorry i was a bad
father son i'm like come on
this was this is supposed to be the safe
you guys are just watching and not
blinking ugh
yeah brutal i don't have a buffer at
least you guys have that but do you have
a good relationship with your dad well
it's it's co-workery you know how it's
hot out
yeah yeah yeah they have a water cooler
in there obviously a small talk right
yeah yeah yeah that's the other thing
about snl is that it's there's something
you're obviously in a corporate
environment even though you're making
comedy sure you're like you're still in
a corporate job so you can't this is
where stand-ups have a hard time there
because it's like it's not about you
right it's just not about you it's a
production yeah it's a production you
are a tiny part of a [ __ ] gigantic
were there any humbling moments like
that where you're like um i barely have
the self-esteem you know what i mean to
like
but walking in
seeing my first sketch
like just completely bomb and being like
oh i have no idea
what to do or how to avoid this next
week and i was like walking up to like
brian tucker is like one of the best
writers he's a great guy one of the best
sketch writers i've ever seen and such a
nice dude and he's been there forever
he's been there for so long yeah he's
been there for a while and he's like he
was head writer for a while and now he's
a senior writer wow um
and he uh
and that was his choice you know what i
mean he was like i i think i'm assuming
and he uh
like
i walked into his office after hearing
my first sketch bomb and i was like hey
brian um
i was like so there are there like any
books i can read like i was like for
real like asking for a book on how to
write sketch because that's how
desperate i was i was like i need some
kind of
i'm like give me some rules some
regulations i don't know how to do this
yeah you know i'm not i didn't come up
in the sketch world i came up doing
comedy and sure you can learn how to
write a joke there's
millions of jokes you can and they're
two lines you know what i mean like the
best ones and so you can go oh there's
the premise that's the turn there's the
punch line boom like
i can see how that works yeah there's
not a ton on sketch you're right you
guys have to watch a bunch i guess you
kind of you gotta like it's like chess i
mean you just have to [ __ ] fail to
get good at it but that's all yeah
that's all any anything in entertainment
right yeah every part you have to kind
of just learn right right yeah but
you're learning on the biggest platform
it's a terrifying yeah yeah
it's scary but i love it i like it it's
it i mean snl it's like just there's no
show like it where
you have to have a new killer sketch
like a whole episode every weekend it's
insane yeah i mean every other show
you kind of take your time
i mean also the live audience there's
something still pretty insane about it
yeah oh yeah yeah it's very cool i
remember like walking through the
showroom on saturday and like seeing the
like on air sign and being like am i in
the 50s like it's so cool
to be in that environment i remember
watching this happening on comedy
central they would do reruns all day
remember back in the day so you just get
like you know ge smith and the saturday
live band you're like oh my god this is
so yeah that what was your favorite era
of snl
i mean
i'd have to say like the 90s were my
favorite era but like that original cast
was just the best oh yeah you know and i
think there's something
that's naturally really nostalgic when
people think about their favorite
time of snl it's always like right as
they were growing every time every time
but i will say
when che got the gig michael che first
got it i mean he was just an open not an
open mic but he was like a working comic
yeah young guy alcoholic fun
friend of ours and he's like come come
to the show and i was like okay and i
remember sitting in his dressing room
and we're just downing tequila yeah and
i was like what are we doing here you
got to go on he's like ah it's fine
and i remember walking the bowels of 30
rock and like looking at stuff all the
photos and the
touch and everything yeah it was amazing
it's amazing i remember walking through
that hall the first day and like it what
hadn't really occurred to me that that i
had gotten the job like i knew that i
had gotten the job but i was like
walking through that hall where you see
every cast member in the writer's
floor and being like well there's every
hero i ever had exactly being like you
don't deserve this right you know what i
mean
yeah i remember sneaking into norm
lauren's office and he's got that uh
window that overlooks the whole stage
and the audience yeah that was pretty
cool and you're like he's been blown in
here
yeah yeah i had to do it
i did i blew him yeah still don't get
the gig
mr norman yeah he's like this is a mad
tv worthy
sasso you do kids in the hall yeah yeah
yeah their new things are supposed to be
good it's great it's really really good
oh yeah yeah yeah always watching on
amazon um yeah it's on amazon do you
know what i just [ __ ] watched that's
here's a wreck for you if you haven't
seen it uh dina hashem text me to watch
uh she's like have you seen who framed
roger rabbit and i was like not since i
was a kid yeah you haven't seen that no
i just watched it you know just she's
like it's noir it's silly it's funny
yeah dude it's great it's so so good
it's incredible it's so good
it's been a while yeah yeah yeah
artistic movie actually i think about it
oh my god it's brilliant yeah i mean to
make it like a clean
the clean jokes like instead of the
wife's [ __ ] around on him it's uh he
she played patty cakes with him yeah
yeah it's great yeah and also
the uh just the way like i love the noir
aspect where you know betty boop is like
yeah i had lost all this work since
since tunes went to colorado and she's
like but i still got it he's like yeah
kid
yes
it's so dumb and great i love it jessica
rabbit the the big gorilla who's the in
the tuxedo is the bouncer oh i used to
love that movie so good the car is funny
this is this is the boulevardier yeah
this is this is stronger
it's good it's pretty much the same
sam's coming in that's a lot a lot more
i am coming back looking forward
this is a terrible i feel like the uh
we're the opposite of role models on
this spot
just you know keep drinking and you'll
kill your hangover exactly exactly hair
the dog baby
same thing for you another round or
would you like something different go
boulevardia with me dude yeah i'll try a
bull let's do it all right we're doing
these with bodega cat is there a part of
you that's glad you're sober for these
after parties cause those get pretty
wild dude there's never a part of me
that's glad i'm sober i'm not okay i'm
never like glad i'm sober unless i'm
like listening to like my friends you
know if i'm on
when i was on the road with bert and he
would wake up in the morning
hung over on that bus i would be like
okay i'm glad i'm sober but it's like
you only get that in the morning you
don't get that at night when everyone's
having fun that's true you know what i
mean but there is like a gift that comes
with it where like i'll leave right
before
[ __ ] goes down yeah that i don't want to
be there for like i get so many calls
being like dude right after you left the
craziest [ __ ] happened
and i'm just i'm always telling the
classic could tell me you should have
hung out man
what happened yeah oh
yeah
and i'm old but i'm always like thank
god i didn't see that yeah it gets like
always one of my friends losing their
mind in front of like in front of people
that matter nothing good happens late i
mean it really i bring vitor on the road
with me for a reason i need a sober guy
to be like don't do that yeah yeah
yeah that's the other thing is like
people uh people know i'm gonna show up
on time that's right i know i'm gonna
like be there i'll be like i'm not gonna
do anything insane yeah you know there's
a darkness to that that's that after
hours you know
with uh there's a lady thing or a woman
starts crying oh something happens
she's always crying always and i don't
know what's happening i know well
neither do they they're not they don't
know why they're crying it has nothing
to do with whatever happened you know
what i mean right right like you ever
see like a table of girls out one night
you're like that's going to end bad
girls are all dressed up always and i
can always i guess
one's going to cry too yeah
i know which one's going to cry yeah
it's always the loudest one yeah the one
that's like
the loudest the most confident she's
leading the [ __ ] party and then when
she cries they all sort of huddle around
her right they all are like it's okay
i made a woman in the crowd cry on
saturday at hilarity's in cleveland i
was uh oh [ __ ] i have one of these yeah
i made her cry i think i told you this
already i don't think i told you but i i
uh
i was it was the day of the abortion oh
i saw the tweets and i just you know i
i'll tell you this too all the jokes
were pro women all the jokes not that it
matters because it's a comedy show but
they were you know i said hey i'm four
women's right the jews here's uh here's
10 minutes of abortion jokes yeah
they're killing one woman starts
hysterically crying she runs out
i don't know i kind of wish we had to
talk like all abortion jokes are
pro-women you know for the most part for
the most part i have one that's
when i cover it up i i tag it with a pro
yeah he calls he calls all women dirty
[ __ ] yeah but you got to be there
no it's uh you know we are still better
than being a comedian
it's an easy joke it's uh some lady
yells at me for telling an abortion joke
and she's like i've had an abortion i'm
like well what you did was worse
but that's not even anti yeah it's just
a joke and then i spin it around yeah
but you know uh thank you i will say
i get i'm not mad when you're offended
honestly because i i get why you're
emotional that sure so i'm kind of like
yeah that's okay it's misplaced i'm not
who you're mad at but i think the left
does that a lot where they will instead
of
instead of being like [ __ ] republicans
or like [ __ ] this overturning they're
like [ __ ] you and i'm like yeah i was
just saying i'm on your side right but
it doesn't matter there's like misplaced
anger
that's true yeah yeah there is a lot of
that i feel like that's um
i don't know i i've i kind of i made
somebody cry this weekend but it wasn't
the
it wasn't over the abortion stuff they
were
um it was like you said i'm keeping it
yeah yeah i ended up keeping it and andy
killed himself
he was like a guy who came to my show
and was like
said some [ __ ] about i guess he listens
to the podcast with me and andy and i
make fun of andy a lot and he makes fun
of me a lot and that's just like our
dynamic right
but then people think that they can do
that right yeah and they don't a they
don't have the skill to do it in a funny
way
and then b they don't [ __ ] know him
right you know so he was trying to like
make fun of him and then
as i was as i was listening this i was
like i could just laugh and like let
this go but then i was like
that's such a shitty person thing that
you know what i mean and i just got
pissed and i was like
hey dude i was like maybe nobody like
ever loved you enough to stand up to you
or stand up for you
and i was like but what you said was uh
[ __ ] rude i was like you know i don't
know you at all and uh you should think
about that next time you talk to a comic
and i just i just was like i was really
honest but this man grown man started to
cry
damn how old are you
i'm talking like 30. oh yeah that's too
old to cry in public yeah yeah this is
on stage to audience no this was after
the show i came out after the show and
he was going into the next show i
thought he was there at the show before
but he was there for the second show so
then i had to perform for this guy
did you do your bit about men who cry
it's just so unattractive right
am i right it's just disgusting yeah
your face is wet but i'm not
nick griffin does a great joke about how
guys when they cry they always try to
toughen it up by throwing a few curse
words in there it's like [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah
yeah you're still you're still crying in
public yeah yeah
it's also just like so uncomfortable
i've never seen a man like uh cry in an
attractive way because they just haven't
for so long yeah so their face looks
constipated
yes yes exactly
their face looks like an [ __ ] that
just [ __ ] the only the only handsome
cry might be and if you can pull this up
peters
what's in the box seven brad pitt
holding a gun
denzel the one teardrop come on oh yeah
but look look how cute his wife's head's
in a box come on
yeah but that's brad pitt that's true
john doe's got the upper hand damn he
looks good crying too yeah he's nice a
hunk pull up the door i don't know
though i don't know you got like look at
his look at his mouth
yeah all right all right you know what
i'm saying you get a wife and head in a
box uh past
[Laughter]
oh that's a good cry
is that a slave cry yeah yeah
love a slave chris denzel jesus christ i
mean not good no it's
good power cinematic
jesus [ __ ] christ
oh no
you're
all right
go back to that last one that's
disgusting who's that who's that guy
harry styles what are the best cries
ever can we get like best fit what's
sally oh you want to talk about a
[ __ ] pet peeve it's people that go on
social media to cry oh i got a good one
that drives me it's [ __ ] crazy i'm
gonna send you a great photo a woman who
left my show crying in tampa
how many movies you racking up this is
from years ago but i had to save the
photo because it's so [ __ ] funny did
she she took a picture of herself crying
yeah and tagged
in the comments i'm sending it to peters
you can pull it up and she wrote this
leaving your show crying you're going to
like this i just jesus christ
see these people are all going through
[ __ ] this guy crying at your show he's
got some issues can you imagine how
insane you'd have to be to take a photo
of yourself send it to a stranger and be
like you made me cry like that i don't
understand in what world is that like
you're getting one in on them i know i
know i don't get it well the cry trumps
things that's why they don't know she is
if you zoom in and says leaving your
show crying
okay you could you can text out the name
we don't give real names here but like
yeah
yeah that's um first of all i don't see
the tears
so that's fake yeah damn
leaving your show crying same haircut as
my mom
surprise surprise what are the best
movie crying scenes i want to see what
they go
milk money i remember
was that melanie griffith yeah she was
hot super hot in that
he's got
what are we gonna do jerk off to this i
don't get it captain phillips
i don't remember that one that's what i
had jerk off i never said men crying
wilson vince is great and captain
david tell joke uh it's not your fault
that's a good crime that's a great crime
that is a great cry i can't even cry
mystic river that was good sean penn
killed that i'm not gonna cry for you
yeah tom cruise is [ __ ] great in
magnolia i'm not gonna cry for you yeah
all of these are uh
all of these are men crying
oh yeah good point yeah well the women
crying would be too long of a list right
they're also like it's not it's not uh
exceptional you know right you know why
because women take photos of themselves
crying
and send them to people that they don't
even know uh yeah no dude has ever done
that no leaving your show crying here's
proof it's like what
i know get it together
crying is definitely a private moment it
is it's like uh i mean maybe i maybe
this is because i was raised by you know
republicans but um
i wasn't encouraged in my house to like
cry like that i i still don't do it in
public like i go to therapy and i'll sit
on the couch and before he even walks in
i'll start crying just because i'm like
well this is where i do this right you
know but like you do the road you write
for snl and you go to therapy every week
i go to not every week i
i do therapy now i do it over the phone
and i do it like once every two weeks
um
but i've been in therapy for like so
long that it's like when i go now it's
like going to get a massage or something
i like literally treat myself to therapy
because i'm like um whatever yeah i
could use it do you ever think where
you're making up stuff because you're
like i'm here no i'm generally like hey
yeah yeah your money but i understand i
totally understand the uh the desire to
do that and i tried i tried to explain
that to my therapist one time and he was
like
so what you think you uh only need this
when things are bad and i was like well
yeah
yeah exactly yeah and go to the gym if
i'm thin right yeah but that's what he
said he goes so do you only he's like
the only way to stay thin is to keep
going to the gym and i was like oh that
checks out that makes sense you know
nonsense like you got to just stay on
top of it he's got you there but you're
not going to the doctor when you're
healthy
no i'm not going to the doctor even if
i'm not healthy know i'm just avoiding
the [ __ ] doctor
yeah do you have health care i do and i
still avoid it i still don't want to
know i'm like don't [ __ ] tell me if i
have a mole that's questionable i'm like
i'll just see yeah we'll find out i'll
do cancer one day i'll find out yeah i'm
just like
i don't want to [ __ ] know
i don't want to know
it's the only thing that i think kept me
from being an opioid addict is that i
didn't i hate the doctor's office wow
good point you know you couldn't get a
script yeah there's no way i would
keep doing a drug that made me go to the
doctors every time right people really
people really [ __ ] opioid thing is
crazy
the obvious but it's like it's crazy
it is so bad i mean especially
considering how we made such a huge deal
out of kovis yes and i i kept thinking
about the op the opioid crisis during
this whole time because i was like well
this is just raging and it's getting
worse yeah and every [ __ ] day i'm
like no one even
it's it's so weird it's people's kids i
know and they pass all these laws where
you can't sue them or whatever and
nobody seems to give a [ __ ] have you
seen dopesick i heard it's good it's
amazing [ __ ] so good michael keaton
is like he's great i think it might be
the best i've ever seen him i'm like
really so [ __ ] good in it it's great
it's heavy it's really heavy it's like
really good and necessary but no one
still cares yeah yeah we need we need a
few more tv shows
yeah i know right what about uh so
you're on the road every week and it's
like it's i mean i was texting you to
club you were having a club was not
treating you well right
yeah yeah i had this experience at a
club once where i like i had texted sam
because i knew i was like who's on the
road and pissed about it
and you got me a week when i was in a i
was in a good mood yeah yeah yeah and i
was like uh i kind of wished that you
had been having a bad weekend because i
was like not on you but just to keep the
bond yeah keep it going yeah cause i was
like there's so much more poison i could
spew about this but i had been all right
so i did this club
and the first day i get there i was like
hey you know are there any dates that i
should be concerned about any like
where the numbers are low like i can
just do a last minute like blast just
[ __ ] promote
and they were like no no it's actually
like we've got better numbers than we've
had in a few weeks and i was like great
all right awesome next day i get there
first show's great second show well like
as the first show is filing out
the manager gets over the pa system
and goes
all right so um
we only have 12 tickets sold to the next
show and we're gonna have to cut the uh
unless we get 15 we're gonna have to axe
the second show and i i'm standing next
to her i'm standing next to her and
she's saying this into a mic and i turn
to her and i go are you um are you
telling me into a microphone
that the sh that the tickets are low
while the audience is filing out right
now
and she goes into the mic she goes i'm
telling you i'm telling the staff i'm
telling your features and i go
okay all right i'm gonna fight this
woman i'm gonna fight this [ __ ] wow i
literally i'm gonna fight her so i asked
her where the other manager was
and she looks
under her she i've never been out white
woman to like this in my life
she looks under her desk like checks
under the desk and then checks in the
sky and goes i don't know where he is oh
and i was like okay
all right
i gotta i'm like i was like raging when
i tell you like you know when you're so
mad you're like shaking yes yes i was
[ __ ] shaking so like michael j fox so
yes
she gave me parkinson's
so i i go find the other manager and i
go hey um so-and-so just uh told me that
the tickets are low uh me and everyone
else um is this something you could have
brought up with me when i asked you
yesterday wow why the ticket sales were
low and um
he was nicer about it but he was like
well no i couldn't have because
you know actually like sometimes they
just go on up on their own and i was
like
sorry for who i was like for me
like i'm not at that in that [ __ ]
position yeah and i know you guys aren't
[ __ ] promoting so what the [ __ ] and i
this messed up it was so messed up wild
so aggressive he was so [ __ ] messed
up and i
i nobody ever came back in the green
room to ask if i wanted anything to eat
nobody like i'm talking two nights in a
row like no and i was like this is was
this club in a mall
yes
but comedy baby
every time every time it's just one of
those where you're like dude are you
pissed that i'm here right
are you upset like it felt like i walked
into their living room that's my pick-up
line by the way are you pissed and i'm
here did i do i don't understand well
that's the thing a lot of these clubs do
now is like if it doesn't sell out or
fill up they're mad at you and you're
like well your job is to kind of bring
an audience in and i entertain them
right that's the job yeah that's what
the job used to be it used to be well
the mall thing is tough because you're
like look
mark and i are on the road almost every
week you know and it's like there's that
thing where you we want to be i really
do like the road
but there is a party that's like yeah
some of these weeks
are filling weeks yeah some of these
weeks like when you're performing next
to a spencer gifts it's hard to you
don't feel like you're living the dream
like you are you pulling up my gigs
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah let's check them out we have coming
up i don't know that's a filler right
there
no i i i literally was looking at my
gigs and i was like i think i sent them
to you and we were laughing yeah you're
like which ones are terrible yeah i was
like i'm gonna give you the honest
rundown yeah yeah i mean i knew which
ones were good because i'd been i mean
all the improvs are [ __ ] amazing i
like these
i really love them they just they kind
of it's a well-oiled machine yeah yeah
they got it down and they just they
treat you like they're happy that you're
there you know that's all it really
takes that's politics honestly i am
happy that i'm there yeah and the thing
is like
you you match i mean i i've said this
again it's funny i met hilarity's in
cleveland recently and uh they play a
thing in the beginning and it's all
these comics you're saying it's a great
club and i'm one of the comics oh it is
a great one and i was like yeah i
[ __ ] mean that because you walk in
there and nick who's the owner who's
just like an awesome dude he meets you
with so much love enthusiasm that you're
just like you feel good yeah right and
then you and also he's a great guy and
like oh my god i mean that guy is like
since i was like a feature there has
been awesome to me yeah so cool and the
food's good the food is so good and uh
it's also nice when you know they love
comedy yeah
right i'm like i'm not part of a money
laundering scheme this is like you know
what i mean we've all been there oh yeah
there's just like you're like glad to be
there because you know that they
appreciate what you're doing money
laundering at a comedy club please don't
be child prostitution please don't be
shy
just sex trafficking
hey better help folks we're brought to
you by better help it's a hell of a
product
now a word
from our sponsor better help you have to
take care of that mind we spend so much
time taking care of our skin or hair or
teeth and so little care on the most
important part the noggin the brain
how well you take care of your brain
affects how you experience life
investing time and energy and mental
health is crucial to being happy eating
right working out getting plenty of
sleep you got to take care of that voice
i know
i went hard and a good start but there's
no substitute for talk therapy
better help makes online therapy
accessible convenient and affordable we
love therapy we got alan he's the best
you got to do it it's crucial it's
important you got to get in there tell
them how to do it sammy ah better help
is online therapy that offers video
phone and chat therapy sessions you can
choose not to see anyone on camera maybe
you're weird-looking maybe you don't
want that therapist talking about that
mole i don't know it's much more
affordable than in-person therapy you
can be matched with a therapist in under
48 hours we might be drunk listeners get
10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com drunk that's better help
help dot com slash drunk
and uh give it a shot get on it
we might be drunk is brought to you by
fanimal
family
this is the summer you're going to go
out and do [ __ ] oh yeah
i'm way ahead of you if you want the
best price for the best shows this
season use fanimal phantomize tickets to
everything with no fees the price you
see is the price you pay for a hot link
like a dodger game lollapalooza fanimal
is the
always cheap option fanimals group
purchase makes it easy to get your
friends together set a size for your
group and choose the number of tickets
you want to pay for yourself then invite
friends when the group size is met
everyone gets charged and receives their
tickets if the minimum size isn't
reached in time nobody gets charged
don't commit until your friends do tell
them how fatty fanimel has amazing
customer service don't take our word for
it check out their hundreds of five star
reviews the next time you need tickets
go to fanimal.com and sign up with code
drunk for 20 of credit toward your first
purchase that's pretty damn good check
out fanimal and experience more
hey folks this summer months are here
the summer months are here time to stay
fueled and hydrated making hydration a
priority helps us feel healthier in our
everyday lives one stick of liquid iv
and 16 ounces of water hydrates you two
times faster and more efficiently than
water alone liquid iv products taste
great 10 refreshing flavors like concord
grape lemon lime pina colada tropical
punch sounds like summer to me
i like the concord grape you know it's
kind of like you're drinking wine but
yet you're getting uh hydrated
i drink one of these every morning just
in case use liquid iv first thing in the
morning before a workout when you feel
run down after a long night out and
manage
to daily d
manage to daily hydration
you need some right now i think i'm
hurting a single serve packaging helps
you keep hydrated while on the go or on
the road i got a pile of these at home
yeah i hit them every day they taste
good they feel good and it's nice to
just know you're hydrated you got a lot
of moving parts you gotta lubricate
folks yeah you need to stay hydrated i
take these all the time too whether to
kill a hangover if you know maybe i swam
some laps or whatever they're packed
with five essential vitamins b3 b5 b6
b12 and vitamin c contains three times
the electrolytes of traditional sports
drinks suck on that gatorade liquid iv
is made with premium ingredients and
free from gluten dairy and soy so if
you're annoying you could also take this
liquid iv uses cellular transport
technology designed to enhance rapid
absorption of water and other key
ingredients into the bloodstream grab
your liquid iv in bulk nationwide at
costco or you can get 25 off when you go
to liquid iv.com and use drunk at
checkout that's 25 off anything you
order when you shop better hydration
today using promo code drunk at iv.com
all right
no but i was i was there and they're
just so nice and nick is like an old
school like cleveland first off he's
like a hot older guy
yeah a greek but he looks like he looks
like the grandpa remember the grandpa
from the show the oc
he looks like that guy we didn't watch
that you never watched that show it was
like it was like the new beverly hills
90210 it's not a good show but anyway
they're telling me this story and
they're like yeah nick [ __ ] there's
some guy's acting up nick grabs him by
the throat he chokes him up and i'm like
he's like old he was like yeah he was
like 65 when he did that
he's choking dudes out in the 60s yeah
just to stand up for the [ __ ] comic
on stage he's like he's like non-racist
clint eastwood and gran torino yeah
that's great yeah
he's greek torino
that's a low-key hilarious movie oh so
funny so literally just non-stop racism
some old slurs you're like oh i forgot
about that slur i forgot that one that's
creative yeah
sort of the only thing white people ever
invented when is he he's like 93 when is
he gonna stop casting himself as the
tough guy i know i know he's like 93
he's got he's like you [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] right right with him in the uh the
new movie at the old folks home where
cuomo
yeah uh
has never mind covered
i'm not dying everybody is dying in the
old folks pulling up this is classic
this is great
god his face looked more and more like a
vagina
i do want to [ __ ] his face
[Laughter]
oh the spit after
oh she out spit him yeah that's that's
[ __ ]
funny they had to have his wife die in
the beginning to make him somewhat
likeable that's true
he's got a puss on
i want to see a vid i want to see one of
him and that lady spitting back and
forth just bigger and bigger
that's the whole movie yeah
[Laughter]
smart to make it asian though it's
somehow less offensive if they're asian
asian people would love that
literally it's called crazy poor asians
it's amazing that it's about an old
white man with a gun saying get off my
lawn and we're like hell yeah dude
yeah we're literally on his side
that is what all when did this come out
when did this come out oh wait oh yeah
holy [ __ ] a lot has changed every show
now there's so many like dude
yellowstone i love yellowstone but
you're literally like rooting for like
old white people to come oh yeah to be
like they should have the whole state
they should own all of them
essentially you're just like
you're like man i'm just i'm just this
show's making me pretty [ __ ]
republican yeah yeah yeah that's why
every dad loves that show right isn't it
i love that yellow sounds fun dude yeah
that's fun
my dad's been trying to get me to watch
it i can't hold that rip
that guy rules he's sexy and he's
banging a native american in it yeah oh
no that's the other guy oh [ __ ] that's
casey yeah sorry rip yeah
oh beautiful let's see what we got jesus
i made this edit
what do you want i live next door come
on get the [ __ ] out of your mouth tell
me what you want and have some respect
[ __ ]
zipper
what
this is going to get us pulled from
youtube
hey it's in the movies over-educated 27
year old version there's a mexican a jew
and a colored guy going
he said colored could have been worse
damn padre
[ __ ] this is a bar you have a drink
what do you want another [ __ ]
it's after one in the afternoon it's
that morning get off my lawn used to
stack [ __ ] like you five feet high in
korea use it for sandbags
get off my lawn
[Laughter]
jesus christ
[Music]
i kept a bunch of jabbering gooks off of
my lawn jesus christ
his pants i love those pants
i
[Laughter]
you should write that just clint
eastwood in the writers room i was
literally thinking i was like this is
like its own [ __ ] sketch
how many [ __ ] face
now get in the truck
shut up [ __ ]
what is all this bro [ __ ] wait is that
anthony soprano
no i wish oh yeah i thought you asian
girls were supposed to be smart
even the compliments are rough
jesus jesus christ
the beginning of that last scene is
hilarious too because he pulls up in the
truck and they're like bothering her or
whatever and
you know
they're trying to jump him they're about
to jump him and he like pulls out he's
about to pull out a gun and he just
pulls out like his finger finger yeah
like oh this shoe is crazy and then he
just pulls out a real gun after yeah oh
yeah
yeah the finger was the foreplay just
like in real life wait how much longer
how much longer was that video
it's five minutes
that's not like a hole
five minutes off that movie i think the
cold would keep all the idiots out what
about that damn what brother ears
this must be a tough one you could shave
five minutes off that movie if you took
out the slurs
that's [ __ ] whoever's
[ __ ] for tnt is like this is exhausting
yeah right you should see uh the gran
torino too it's in wuhan
he's working damn bad i haven't seen
either of them i i literally haven't
seen either of these movies in like in
full oh that's great it's a fun one
it's ridiculous but
yeah eastwood is great
it's crazy to me that that was made in
2008 oh yeah
a lot of fun stuff was like it's like
watching blazing saddles or something
you know where you're like you're like
what how how was this ma like it's crazy
i won't say unforgiven is one of the
best movies ever great that's a eastwood
is a is a incredible filmmaker although
million dollar baby
stinks yeah i never even saw it oh it's
such a cartoon it's really bad and it
won best picture
i think that was just like well the best
part is that he sings the song on the
trail in the end in the credits for this
it's just him singing wait i don't
remember that pull that up eastwood just
sings
like this is more offensive than the
slurs no no pull up
it's gran torino he's singing the song
in the credits i remember being in this
movie theater like what
yikes
is he singing it to a chair
that was a big moment
[Music]
what the [ __ ]
he's like lizzo he does it all
except he's laying down the couch
because he's screaming so many slurs
he's tired he's like oh [ __ ] he took it
out of me yeah
[Music]
young tom waited a great voice oh yeah
he just smoked and drank himself into
having like this scratchy janice joplin
voice right but she died so young we
never really heard bad janice dude but
that was i mean it's like
she didn't need to age yeah like
come on come on stevo's got that now
you're like holy [ __ ] you sound insane
yeah really does smoking yeah stevo josh
adam meyers
i got the
drug addict voice yeah
damn yeah dude he was tom wade's is
[ __ ] awesome that first album he
wrote he was like 24. wow and it's like
the most mature [ __ ] you've ever heard
tom waits there's another wreck for you
if you haven't heard his album closing
time or rain dogs they'll blow your
[ __ ] mind yeah this is pretty
fascinating
the joker oh yeah yeah
funny guy too have you been here in
australia
i got here last night
oh yeah
holy [ __ ] that is heath ledger why so
serious
that was a fascinating flight
oh my god i don't know what are you good
sally it's [ __ ] scary
well they show movies that are not
that's insane it sounds just like the
joker
i [ __ ] love tom weights yeah yeah he
goes so such a sexy guy and also like
really um i don't get i don't listen to
him that often because if i do i'm like
well that's gonna be my day
right you know what i mean that's like a
meal that you can't digest
fully
it's going to [ __ ] with you for the rest
of the day right i'm like if i need to
be in a good mood i can't listen to this
yes but
that image from rain dogs they recreated
that for fight club
oh is that right so you know the scene
where ed norton is against meatloaf's
tits yes that's hugging that's uh the
cover of rain dogs
so rain dogs like that song is awesome
but that song is i think basically like
i think it's about it i could be wrong
here but i think it's about a drunk
because it's like about how dogs when
they get wet they lose their sense of
smell and can't find their way home
right so it's just about a drunk like i
can't get home i'm too drunk
a lot of his songs are like i'm sure
yeah look at that
that's fight club right yeah yeah yeah
isn't that crazy yeah
[ __ ] tits
that's why the fight club is cool so fun
palace
r.i.p meatloaf man oh yeah
anti-venom when did he die he died like
during covenant five months ago yeah
really
missed that yeah he was yeah
that went right over my [ __ ] head
yeah
there's i mean there's just been too
many it's like everyone's dying now like
we're getting to the age where the
people that we watched growing up
they're all dying off and you're like oh
[ __ ] just don't even look you know
what's the precursor to death is like
seeing the shows you watched as a kid on
nick at night yes you're like oh [ __ ]
yeah fresh prince is on nick at night
now right [ __ ] 30 rocks this is god and
then you walk into urban outfitters
they're selling our bands t-shirts as
like what are they selling sonic yeah
nirvana pearl jam all that [ __ ] you're
like holy hell green day yeah
that's like and that was like a few
years ago that they started doing that i
know i know like when your musicians
stop
when they stop going up shirtless you're
like [ __ ]
you're like [ __ ] he's gotten fat yeah
yeah
and iggy pop and jagger are still thin
in the chili peppers they're sticking
with the shirtless didn't jagger didn't
he uh relapse recently
i think he had him
he had like a heart surgery or something
he had a sort of he has something
happened well that would i mean
painkillers man
that song the traveler is that it the
passenger that's a great tool he's still
pretty ripped he looks great looks like
anthony kiedis
but he's got that old he's got that like
leathery yeah
creep skin would you
ugh
no no
all right there's an episode of board
you can't watch your hands go into
someone's chest like that
gross you feel like you're playing with
gak
another timely reference
he's like a full body stretch armstrong
right yeah
no thanks
no he's awesome though and he
uh think
dude that is [ __ ] old junkie body
you know what's [ __ ] up though that's
best case scenario for all of us oh
that's true yeah
yeah
that's a horror movie like if you see
that in dim lighting but he's got a
candle gets snuffed out before he walks
in a doorway pull up his age though how
old is iggy pop tan white walker yeah
yes his stomach looks like a rich lady's
neck
yeah
yeah how old are we talking here
dude he looks amazing amazing that's my
dad's age i think it's bourdain and iggy
in miami i think it's the miami app yeah
on the beach and it's like oh man i
remember that talking about have you
guys seen the bourdain documentary
[Music]
it's great it's really good i like them
so much i don't want to accept yeah i
don't that's like i'll watch it at some
point but i don't accept i i watch a
show well it's interesting
i never really watched the show i wasn't
into him like that but then i watched
this documentary and i was like okay
well now i'm like
now i'm in like i did not even know
about this guy i didn't watch the show
everybody was telling me to and so
obviously i went like no
and uh
because whenever people like push
something on me i'm like [ __ ] you i
don't know i don't want to watch like if
four people tell you to watch it you'll
watch it but if eight do you're like go
[ __ ] yourself yeah exactly like i won't
watch top gun so many people are like oh
you know to see top gun i'm like i'm
fine i don't need to see it i went to go
see the black phone though that's
[ __ ] i heard it's good
right yeah
so what is that about the cricket
all right
[Laughter]
that took me a second that is the
dumbest stephen king stephen king's son
wrote a short story and they based this
off of that
oh cool
yeah someone rhonda was just telling me
hated this but then sean murphy was
telling me he really liked oh i loved it
both smart guys tough to call it
a [ __ ] snob he is
i mean he's one of my best friends he's
the biggest [ __ ] movie [ __ ] i've ever
met he's dude it's so great
[Music]
would you give me my hat oh boy
this is black phone yeah okay this
summer
ethan
a pedophile
ethan hawk is joaquin phoenix
yeah i still haven't seen everything
everywhere all at once everyone's time i
haven't either yeah i haven't seen that
either it's amazing
one bad review it's uh like
in the classic like hong kong comedy uh
like stephen chao like kung fu hustle oh
so it's like that but like you know
multiverse and a little more cerebral
but it's it's awesome
it's great like a cerebral film yeah
it's really funny but it's hilarious
like it's it's amazing physical comedy
just like in kung fu there's some scenes
that are clearly like just reflective of
that so it's comedy it yeah it's mostly
common it's a comedy and then they're
also they also do have like some kind of
like you know this like mental component
of like but it's mostly just funny
that's
no not the main character the supporting
actress who's also like the one of the
producers on it um
white lady yes white i know you're
talking about exactly what she's not
jamie curtis jamie curtis yes yes and
she's awesome she wears like a fat suit
it's hilarious she's like the villain
for half the movie oh that's great oh
fat suit i love jamie lee curtis oh yeah
andrew wanda her title girl she's got
true lies yeah remember growing up the
whole thing about her being a
hermaphrodite yes that was a weird thing
when you'd be like she's hot and you'd
have that kid growing up who's like
she's a hermaphrodite you're weird right
and you're like she's not yeah she just
had short hair in the 90s
that's how we reacted and even if she
was i would still uh motorboat still do
it
yeah
what do i care
[Laughter]
[Music]
i think he's one of the best comedic
actors oh yeah
hold on she's about to find her groove
man what a bod on this milf great bod
by the way she's like younger than you
yeah she's like oh really you're
cornering milf because of now but oh
[ __ ] i guess you're right true lies was
fun as hell
movie yeah arnold shined tom arnold was
so funny in this match i know and that
was it
hey don't knock the stupids bro
uh no this is uh
yeah
if you didn't tell me this was true lies
i'd 100 think that was a vampire movie
oh yeah you know the lighting
just that scene is like just twilight
that's
true but that's the only thing with like
men's movies is like which i i mean i
know true lies isn't like a man's but it
is and like they're all shot with this
like blue filter so it's like i
automatically just go oh that's for
dudes yeah like ozark is like all blue
we can't have too much color or we think
we're gay
oh my god
this was like a risk to have short hair
yeah because people were like what are
you doing yeah i knew it
i'm fairly certain this is the second or
third time we watched this clip on the
show
sal accused
you guys just haven't jerked off yet
this is pretty twerking you know like
this was a pre-internet porn this is a
big deal yeah i mean that's great
turn this off i'm getting distracted
it's too hot
this is also when white women were still
dancing those yeah yeah those 80s movies
were like we were we were like the
spandex with the [ __ ] things i
remember like moms picking their kids up
from school
in dc like just [ __ ] in those things
like
i'm like we just we're just looking at
your [ __ ] you know what i mean just it
was a better highlight
it was crazy you know it's funny when
they wear a belt with that thing like
it's spandex yeah yeah there's no it's
just purely decorative yeah white women
dancing is kind of like when you see bob
cousy just dribbling a basketball like
this
that's not
that ain't happening anymore right
right we're done with that i think the
camel toe a lot of people a lot of women
assume is is bad but i think i think
guys like a camel yeah i don't think we
assume it's bad i think we i mean we've
caught on we're like oh camel toe [ __ ]
no i think we've caught on yeah but i
cause i remember pulling getting pulled
over when we were shooting the letterman
thing the director who's a woman pulls
me over and goes hey i just have a quick
note for you and i was like i'm in
trouble or whatever she was like we were
picking up a little camel toe really
yeah and i was like no i know
i was like that i'm fully aware good for
you of that that's just i said the same
thing to him yeah they actually kind of
did do you remember that when they made
me restart my set at letterman why why
because i had my phone like i was
wearing tight jeans and my phone in my
in my pocket they're like i get my first
joke off and i get to laugh and i'm like
all right here we go after the races
like yeah sam i just hear a voice
mid-setting no god
sam
i was like what they're like you got to
restart your set there's a there's a
phone in your in your pocket and i just
panicked i go no it's my [ __ ]
i got like something on that but though
you got to restart your set and
letterman like runs over he's like you
piece of [ __ ] [ __ ] you like trying to be
funny with it and then he grabs me close
and he goes i'm so sorry
yeah he gets it yeah yeah i mean i had
to restart my set but uh we both had
crotch related uh yeah mishaps
[Laughter]
yeah congratulations rated pg-13
[Laughter]
starring kate hudson and tom arnold
with clint eastwood as the racist uncle
[Laughter]
yeah that was a fun set though
that was fun yeah we didn't get that you
he invited us to his green room before
that was [ __ ] weird i know he's
hanging with letterman i know he's
awesome he was so you went in before me
and you were like he's nice yeah yeah he
was really nice what was your what was
your experience um he was just very cool
like i was just i was like he's so
[ __ ] cool and it just felt like
hanging with like you guys it felt like
hanging out with a comic yeah you know
and i didn't expect that because he's a
legend sure so i just thought all right
well
uh you know like this will be kind of
painful for me but we'll get through it
and like he just made me so comfortable
and like
i'm so glad he did that because he knows
like we could have gotten in our [ __ ]
heads about it yeah like just sitting
upstairs surrounded by like agents and
managers which is like oh you had like
20 friends there i had norman no i have
two i had norman like no you had so many
friends no those were all agents and
managers i know but there's people for
you
i literally had norman and one of my
agents came for the berkwitzer was there
for the early show
but you were normal there i had like
someone the whole time right i literally
said everyone else there had like a
whole crew and i was like i'm basically
alone but uh that's the way to do it i
feel like it is now you know what i kind
of like having people there just because
it makes it feel like it's not big
right people there they just distract
you they just go on you do your thing
but when you're solo you're just kind of
like in your head like oh [ __ ] i gotta i
gotta bring it yeah i guess you're right
it kind of prevents you from like
overthinking anything exactly yeah i
never thought of it like that dave was
cool as [ __ ] i mean
uh
it is interesting some interviewers will
like be like i want it to all be real
first words i'll ever say to you will be
on camera but all he really did like
we're not burning anything he was just
like friendly yeah we were just nice he
was just like oh you know
just being like hey whatever you want
this to be it'll be what do you say to
you
um i can't remember because i was on
like two hours of sleep mm-hmm like i
had done because you came from snl i
came from science wow
what a what a career dude i flew there
yeah it was a great year a 24-hour
24-hour uh dude i flew there that
morning to l.a and i to la yeah and i
got off uh i got off stage and
got into a car and [ __ ] flew back
for the show on saturday and then you
laid next to lizzo like oh [ __ ] yeah
yeah
yeah i mean that's probably why when i
was like looking at her conducting
herself i was like oh that's how you do
it yeah so you you were on the next
morning you were out that next morning
again
we were on the same flight no yeah no i
took a red eye back and that was a red
eye yes and went to damn 30 rock and
what did you sleep on the flight i mean
kinda but like i was psyched i was like
that was the moment where when i was
flying home where i was like i can't
believe how [ __ ] cool what i just did
was i know yeah cause on the way there i
was like i gotta get there i gotta have
all my [ __ ] together but what you just
hope they edited it properly like cause
we we did what we set out to do but then
you're like it's in their hands now yeah
but the editor i know the editor cause
he works at snl
so i was like i know him you know what i
mean i was like and i knew that he was
gonna do a good job it's not like i have
i wasn't gonna like be in his ear or
anything but
he let me know like yeah i'm editing
your set and i was like oh cool look you
know i didn't want to ask to see it or
anything i was like just do it i can't
get involved because after editing my
special i was like i can't ever look at
that [ __ ] again it's too much it's too
much you just hope yeah i mean i i do
want to see stuff always but yeah it's a
lot of it's a lot of work and you you
don't i i really genuinely believe that
you can't as a stand-up edit your [ __ ]
correctly because
you you need somebody who can do comedy
editing
like who understands the timing of [ __ ]
totally but if you edit your own
stand-up special like
like i had to it's it's not
you're not going to do it you're not an
editor you know what i mean it's like
it's not your skill set you should be in
the room if you can be i think yeah i
agree
i have a great editor for my new one i
got a clint eastwood
you know no i was on the flight back
that next morning i remember and i was
doing the vegan theater then i was like
a big gig for me and i remember you know
being on no sleep i'm on the flight with
chris distefano he's right behind me
right he's like he's like massage me
he's like you got to get at least two
hours man yeah he's gotta get at least
two hours and i passed out and as i woke
up i turned around he was like yeah
that's great why do you sleep
but imagine hearing that well first of
all kudos to you because a lot of people
would go wait i gotta go to snl then fly
to l.a do this then fly a red eye back
yeah but you got a diesel vegas of
course but i think a lot of people would
have turned that down no he's turning
that [ __ ] down
the logistics are no good it's too much
i don't know i mean i knew that the
logistics were not good and i get like i
i understand turning it down if you
think that you wouldn't be able to that
you wouldn't be able to perform at the
you know what i mean but like
you got to do it yeah you're the [ __ ]
adrenaline it like kicks in you get on
stage and all of a sudden however tired
you are it's just like it doesn't matter
yeah you know you just although i did
answer questions on there that i was
like oh i shouldn't have answered that
like there was i think he asked me
i was making fun of like
some story where i woke up in the middle
of the night and i was like having a
panic attack and i asked andy if i could
see his credit card debt
and i was like i need to know
i need to know how much credit card debt
you're in and uh
and so
letterman asked me he goes well how much
debt is he in and i just gave the exact
number i just said it on tv yeah cause
my defenses were down i had nothing to
be like oh don't do that say this like
make a joke i just [ __ ] told him
i was like god i really [ __ ] hope
they don't use that and thank god they
did you're hoping it's oprah and she
just covers it yeah right yeah dude i
like i went home and i turned to annie
and i was like dude
i'm so sorry
did they use that in the final thing no
you you know what's interesting though
it's like he'd ask some stuff that we
were prepared for obviously not prepared
not like i had like long bits ready but
like some stuff you're like oh i can
hand i know what's coming yeah but then
he'd throw some stuff my way that i was
like i didn't know he's gonna ask me
that right and i think it's kind of good
it's a good mix because
some of my best lines were riffs yeah
you know they weren't things i was like
i'm going to say this they were like
yeah you know i'm i'm trusting the
muscle memory here of just right years
of doing stand-up right yeah just being
able to talk and make it funny you know
and also like i i felt like the
interview gave you a chance to like be
funny in a different way you didn't have
to necessarily do a joke joke like
because you have the interaction and so
different things could happen you know i
like seeing what that's kind of what i'm
[ __ ] with on stage right now is just
like because i have always been like
a writer like i'm like i want to write
it's got to be perfect and like i don't
want to
you know there's something about that
where you can kind of like hide behind
the jokes a little bit oh yeah and i'm
like i'm trying to get comfortable on
stage in a way where i don't necessarily
have to
i want to keep the jokes but
i want to be more comfortable i want to
feel like yeah you're unstoppable yeah
you can go riff on the room [ __ ] with a
guy go back in the material right yeah
that's really uh
the top level yeah performing yeah it's
like when you get off when when you
watch a comic and they're really great
you're like [ __ ] they're a good writer
and like i just want to hang out with
them i want to know what they're like
yes the weird thing is i think that
comes from not giving a [ __ ] yeah which
you can only get from just doing it over
a million times for years and years yes
yeah by the amount of time if you if you
do your fourth set in the night you're
kind of like yeah well i got three good
ones so far let's [ __ ] we're playing
with house money let's have some fun and
that one's the most loose and
interesting yeah and sometimes you bomb
but sometimes that bomb is good for you
too
yeah you i mean
it's funny as much as i [ __ ] on like
look
doing four sets in a night can be dumb
as [ __ ] sometimes it can be a waste but
other times you need that fourth show to
be like i'm going a different way with
this joke yeah i want to see what the
[ __ ] and you find a line then i'm like i
didn't think i'd find it do you have any
do you have any peeves or anything oh
yeah
oh yeah yeah i got a ton i mean are you
are we talking just stand up peeves or
anything maybe anything okay so yeah for
the first is um
seeing a kid in first class
that's a great one that always [ __ ]
pisses me off like every time especially
when you're one away from the upgrade
yes yes yes i get so mad i'm just like
what the [ __ ] is this that's an ad for
an abortion right there
and their feet don't even hit the ground
you're like you don't even need that big
seat yeah they're kicking their dumb
legs i got i get so [ __ ] mad yeah
yeah that drives me insane like and when
my dad i used to fly with my dad and my
mom all the time and they would fly
first class and they would kick me and
my [ __ ] sisters in the back and
they'd come they'd get us when we uh
before we got it you don't need it
anyway right yeah you kind of want to
see a flight attendant just come with
like a rag and go
get the kid in the closet or something
them in the overhead the seat just
opened up i also think kids are better
behaved when they're not with their
parents that's true you know what i mean
i i really do i think you put them in
the back of the plane and then they're
just they just chill they're like true
because other adults are terrifying you
can't [ __ ] around with some old fat guy
like some
clint eastwood guy next to you like shut
the [ __ ] up
yeah okay sorry yeah nobody loves you
back here yeah you know what i mean yeah
yeah dude
you gotta earn enough money to get up
there
good one
yeah
i oh sorry no keep going well i had one
about uh you ever have this one where
the guy goes uh
he goes you gotta try this this chair
it's a very comfortable chair you sit in
the chair and you're like this is very
comfortable goes i told you like
i know that's why i'm sitting in it
that is a specifically male problem i
think yes yes that's definitely
something men do together wanting to
credit yeah
i told you when you like agreed already
like yeah yeah i'm on board i get that
with a lot i have a friend who'll send
me videos like oh it's funny he's like
yeah i'm like yeah you didn't make the
video i know
what the [ __ ] are we doing it was good
good job finding it everyone's a [ __ ]
curator now yeah yeah just because
they've got the internet
good job finding a video that probably
someone else sent to you yes yeah give
me and i told you when i when i didn't
believe you and then you proved me right
yeah the twin towers will
fine to be in trouble that'll be fine i
i think be
told you that i'll get all right i'll
give you that one i do feel like uh that
is one of the ways that like dudes can
kind of relate to um being coerced into
sex is like if you've ever been shown a
youtube video you didn't want to watch
by a good friend
you know
you're like oh [ __ ] oh fine
okay
thumbs down
yeah
[Laughter]
you're like i'll play nice i guess the
ending will it'll pick up in the end
i gotta pee for you i'm at the uh
village underground bathroom there's one
sink there right and there's a guy just
lingering slicking his hair
the wet the wet water you know what it
is all the water's wet the water he's
wetting his hair he's just doing this
and i'm just like i'm trying to wash my
hands i have to watch this guy then he
does the same thing in front of the
towel machine he's just like
ew
and you're like getting get out it's so
small right
the that you're like you're just now
watching him get ready right because
you're just in that space with him so
you're just standing next to him while
he does it right
that's true you also we have phones if
you want to do the mirror thing do it in
your [ __ ] phone you don't need the
mirror right you got that just take it
outside if there's multiple if you if
you're alone do whatever you want but if
there's a weight be respectful of other
people right yes and the guys who get
too comfortable in the bathroom in a new
york bathroom get out of here yeah come
on oh you know what else is [ __ ]
annoying
ayahuasca people oh my god i just did
one of these ayahuasca people
i did one of these recently really
no i went on a date with a woman a while
back and she was like pushing ayahuasca
on me yeah like it's ten years of
therapy and one night and i said that
sounds [ __ ] horrible yeah i'm not
doing that
and also if that's the case why do you
have to do it once a year what is
happening to you ah true they're always
like yeah it's 10 10 years of therapy
i'm like well you just said you do it
every month exactly and if you're so
enlightened then why are you on a date
with me just kneel
does neil do it i assume really
constantly he took chris rock with him
wow
yeah yeah
yeah damn ayahuasca people is a great
one it didn't drive me nuts yeah
cohn was a big ayahuasca guy but i
didn't seem annoying about it if you do
you do whatever drugs you want just
don't be [ __ ] annoying and also just
like say you're doing drugs stop telling
me you're doing therapy yeah like stop
dressing it up you know what i mean
right just you go to the wood like
you're going to the woods to do drugs
all right that's what's happening you're
not [ __ ] it's it's like this is a
shaman he doesn't have a degree yeah all
right it's not a [ __ ] joke that like
really freaks me out is like the idea of
if you don't like really intimately know
someone who's doing that you're just
doing like that drug tourism thing and
like chile or something and like you're
in the jungle with some random dude
right and he's gonna [ __ ] get you all
[ __ ] up out of your head and then
leave you in the jungle i know you wake
up in the gym like in pulp fiction
like you know you're supposed to get
into like a good head space before you
do any of that i don't think that would
be possible for me if some dude took me
into the middle of uh i don't know if
that's possible for me after 10 years of
therapy like getting in a good head
space i've never been in it is only one
night
well shrooms you won't even do with
randos but you gotta do this with randos
in the jungle yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah and they tell you to like go off
your meds like if you're on meds you got
to go off your meds for like 10 for like
30 days beforehand i got to go with my
cancer medication i'm doing an eyewash
right
it's all these like self-healers that
are like they're all over in the
internet and they're like they're just
and i've seen a lot of comics that like
didn't do well in comedy be like i'm a
healer now
the saddest thing i've ever seen and i'm
just like just say you failed at
whatever it is
i
i've literally i've never seen anybody
who like quit wall street to go do like
tibetan sound
[Laughter]
you know i'm a stand-up healer yeah it's
[ __ ] sad that's what it is you know
two bartenders and two stripper former
shippers in miami who are healers there
you go yeah it's always somebody that
you're like all right well i i don't i'm
not even convinced you [ __ ] healed
you're a clear healer right and there
and they're always like they're telling
you like people who have real mental
like disorders they're like yeah just
you can heal yourself you can heal your
own trauma i'm like oh my god these are
it's going to be a nightmare first i
want out of a conversation with you
casually like you think i'm going to go
[ __ ] pay money to go to a jungle with
you
some of these healers i mean and it also
is really disrespectful there are people
out there like there are chiropractors
and massage therapists and
acupuncturists who are like legitimately
gifted at what they do yeah so when
these people are just like i'm a healer
you don't get to call yourself that no
that's like calling yourself one of the
greats right other people say that [ __ ]
about you yeah or you're not a healer
that's my favorite
that's the gen z version
i'm iconic it's like okay all right
i was thinking of eddie murphy when you
think
exactly he's a healer yeah yeah he
watches movies you feel a little better
yes that's healing 100 i watch i mean
dude 90 professor i've said it on this
podcast but many times i've gotten some
[ __ ] for it but like he should have
gotten an oscar for that
that movie's insane yeah oscars right
nine roles yeah yeah incredible
that's a healer that's a real [ __ ]
heal
but they can't do that it's like the
guys who teach comedy
yeah yeah
yeah i took a class with mackie when we
started oh yeah did you yeah did it help
yeah all right it was just a place to
get up what wasn't an open mic so there
was like one supportive room oh it's me
you got up yeah it's good yeah yeah no
it wasn't like it was just but like yeah
i'm glad i took it
there's some there's some comic strips
there's some comics that do like teach
classes where i'm like okay that's cool
like i know jess kirsten taught a class
for a little while yeah yeah yeah that's
your teacher yeah you're [ __ ] s
you're in yeah right hand right yeah
she's incredible she's a healer yes
that's a healer
that's a healer
that's a hashtag right there right
healer
everyone everyone everyone comment
healer on this video
do you want to should we plug do you
want to plug anything yeah where are you
going to be yeah um i'm going to be
at laugh boston i have to update my
website there's like dates that i
haven't touched in months so uh i have
to update everything but i will be at
laugh boston when does that say the 19th
and the 20th of august yeah yeah and
then um good time why does it say the
stand oh because they just automatically
put it on bands in town um
anyway so i will have it updated good
club yeah it's a great club but also uh
really just want to plug my special go
watch my special whiskey yes so on
comedy central's youtube
yeah that's they've got so many things
on there that i'm like it's sort of like
plateaued right now and i'm like i gotta
get it we'll get it back up yeah well
you can see rose but also she'll be in
uh edmonton at uh the comic strip uh in
september
uh
and many more dates watching watch your
special listen to her podcast with andy
what's up find your beach find your
beach yeah oh there you go yeah life's a
beach
then you die yeah
i'm uh i don't know when this comes out
i have no idea
okay so i'll be all over the vogel and
jersey uh let's see
wise guys comedy club in utah count
basie center for performing arts
whatever that is
keep going keep going
yeah we got the houston improv san
antonio lol comedy off broadway and
lexington
um
keep going
comedy connection in providence that's a
fun one and uh yeah all kinds of stuff
improv and dinner theater i don't even
know where that is
the aura i think that's in portland
brandon i think that's in uh
seattle
this show i don't think toronto
in seattle yeah richard
doing the neptune that's doing the red
rocks doing the uh san jose who knows
this is all off i got to get a new web
person uh yeah when you get them please
let me know who they are
buffalo san jose la pittsburgh dania
beach louisville irvine [ __ ] uh omaha
phoenix lexington new brunswick oklahoma
city all over uh
i'll see kansas city fort wayne on
thanksgiving that'll be upbeat uh oh boy
samrel.com
we might be drunkpod.com for the merch
we've got the patreon which you guys are
loving we got uh
bodega cat whiskey is coming very soon
soon very very soon like i'm literally
thinking like two or three weeks from
now probably hallelujah i'll believe it
when i see it yeah yeah there
christopher you hear us
get on it [ __ ] yeah and check
out rosebud on the road check out her
special and praise allah
[Music]
[Music]
naked samuel is feeling dangerous
i'm out to lunch here in new
orleans this woman doesn't look like i
remember her and i get down in the same
way
we might
[Music]